david so let's first talk about what we
mean when we talk about these sensitive
groups who are should probably stay
inside we're talking about our elderly
neighbors people who have respiratory
diseases like if you know you have
asthma probably not great to be outside
right now also keep doors and windows
closed that's pretty much for all of us
because we're always sort of scratching
our eyes in the weather like this first
though or second i should say let's show
you this video crystal sending us this
new video she says this was in the
northwest part of the valley near texas
station we're going to play this out
because as you see those trees narrowly
missing those cars there
in the parking lot where she lives so
thankfully no damage there all right
let's take a look at some of the outages
the electricity outages we're seeing
right now the good news is they're
actually going down we're about 3 000
customers without power all across
nevada and down here where we are in
southern nevada we're at 112 customers
without power so that's pretty good news
taking a look if you are flying out of
harry reid international things are
pretty good we're seeing some delays as
you get later into the day pretty much
as those flights stack up but not too
bad if you are heading out of town
tonight brian denise back over to you